As a creature that had spent so much of its
existence in captivity surrounded by beings
it deemed disgusting, SCP-682 was not used
to having seemingly unlimited freedom to explore
and was even less used to having tolerable
company.
And yet, here the hard-to-destroy reptile
was entering into Level 21 of the Backrooms
with not one - but two accidental companions.
The Backrooms were bad enough when faced alone,
and the addition of annoying hangers-on only
made the whole experience that much more unbearable
for 682.
Even the fact that SCP-682 was free of the
Foundation was little consolation when being
contained in the Backrooms was proving to
be a far more terrible fate than a lifetime
spent in a vat of acid.
The first and most important was the infinitely
lovable and perfect blue hyacinth macaw Jerry
- who SCP-682 had known for only 12 levels
of Backrooms but would undoubtedly kill everything
in sight if anything happened to him.
Of course - the lizard tended to want to do
that anyway, but the sentiment was strong
nonetheless.
682 felt the complete opposite way about the
Plush Dino - Backrooms Entity 198 - that had
been tagging along ever since Level 18.
There was something about its dumb little
smiling face that filled 682 with a boiling
rage.
Not to mention the fact that having the animated
toy around would mean that Jerry’s much-desired
attention would be split between it and 682.
Three was most certainly a crowd and, if the
tiny-legged scamp wasn’t so proficient at
dodging 682’s unprovoked claw strikes and
tail slaps, 682 would cut the plush dino out
of the equation.
But 682 would need to conserve some energy
for the entities that lurked in the Backrooms
Level 21 - a series of four hallways.
Yes, you heard that right.
There were only four hallways in Level 21.
Not infinite hallways, not a labyrinth of
hallways, not even the same four hallways
repeated in an endless loop.
Four Hallways.
That’s it.
As a consequence of the smaller scale of level
21, the roving bands of entities that normally
are spread out across a much larger dimension
find themselves clustered together in the
cramped linear span of the four hallways.
Even a medium entity count can be impossibly
dangerous when an explorer is faced with the
iconic Backroom monsters at once.
Well, unless those entities are up against
SCP-682.
“Go on.
Make my day!”
it roared.
The approaching regiment of death moths, death
rats, facelings, hounds, bursters, smilers,
clumps – and even some completely unknown
weirdos – marched like soldiers.
Specifically, the gorgonites from the 1998
action/comedy movie Small Soldiers - because
these things were equally messed up looking
and equally known for fighting losing battles.
However, as SCP-682 charged into the horde,
it noticed that this time the entities were
a bit more tactical in the way that they approached
combat.
Was this also a unique property of Level 21
or was the Backrooms taking a page out of
682’s book and adapting to new threats?
The Clumps vaulted with their many hands and
rolled along the walls to get behind 682,
while the hounds and facelings made a frontal
assault.
The smilers soon joined the clumps on the
other side, using their uncanny ability to
shift through the shadows.
The death rats gnawed at 682 from underneath,
attacking the reptile’s footing, and doing
everything they could to distract it.
All the while, the death moths and bursters
acted as artillery.
Shooting acidic slime from a safe distance
behind the other entities - or in the case
of the death moths from above: just out of
SCP-682’s reach.
SCP-682 almost had to applaud the pathetic
entities for getting their act together.
It was facing a mobile task force made up
of rejected Dungeons and Dragons monsters.
A valiant effort, but doomed to end in their
defeat.
These entities were not the Foundation, and
SCP-682 refused to lose to a bunch of aberrations
cosplaying as a containment squad.
It was time to give them a taste of their
own medicine.
Enduring the attacks of many entities at once,
SCP-682 became a chimera of monstrous features
stolen from various Backrooms entities.
The freakish grin of a smiler spread across
its face, while the grasping arms of a clump
emerged from its back along with an impressive
pair of death moth wings.
The ever-disgusting acid-shooting pustules
of a burster appeared across 682’s body,
pointing in every direction like the cannons
on a naval ship.
Now fully-optimized to take down the organized
entities with their own weapons, SCP-682 roared
out a battle cry:
“DEATH TO THE BACKROOMS”
All burster pods ruptured at once, forcing
the entities to take evasive actions.
Most didn’t get far, thanks to 682’s countless
clump arms which grappled and held onto everything
within reach.
As 682 pulled the entities in towards its
teeth and claws, the shredding began.
Their numbers were thinned quickly, and the
once-organized legion fell in disarray - with
entities indecisively making desperate attacks
or tactical retreats.
Now the resemblance between this skirmish
with the entities on Level 21 and the ones
that SCP-682 had with mobile task forces back
at The Foundation containment facility was
nearly perfect.
Except this time, no force, military or otherwise,
would come along to put SCP-682 back into
confinement.
Now this was freedom!
“Did you see that, Jerry?
That was classic 682.
I still got it!”
The reptile boasted.
“Sqawk classic squawk.”
Jerry replied.
In the excitement of victory, SCP-682 almost
forgot that Entity 198 was still here.
Watching the aftermath of the carnage with
the same smile that it always wore.
Nevertheless, 682 felt rather strongly that
the Plush Dino was judging it.
“Nobody asked you, Plush Dino.”
It grumbled.
On some level, the Plush Dino was most likely
aware of SCP-682’s overwhelming animosity,
but it was also a simple entity driven by
appropriately simplistic desires.
It had its own reasons for staying by the
reptile’s side.
In its usual role on Level 18, the plush dino
would seek out explorers lost in their own
traumatic memories and guide them towards
safety: whatever safety meant in the Backrooms.
The adorable entity had an inherent biological
or supernatural radar sense that allowed it
to detect individuals experiencing distress
and suffering.
Since the majority of Backrooms explorers
are human, the margin of distress that the
plush dino could detect and respond to was
kept within the relative limits of normalcy.
For this reason, The Plush Dino had never
encountered any being that carried more feelings
of distress than 682.
The hard to destroy reptile was, from Entity
198’s perspective, the most mentally pained
creature in existence.
The Plush Dino’s top priority was now to
be a beacon of hope for what it saw as a victim
of the ultimate forms of unaddressed trauma.
Of course, it was nonverbal entity and possessed
no telepathic or empathic abilities, so conveying
its more wholesome therapeutic intentions
to SCP-682 was next to impossible.
Especially since a being as aggressive and
hateful as 682 would be wholly unreceptive
to the notion of hugging away its problems.
But this wouldn’t stop Entity 198 from making
the rehabilitation of its now keter-class
charge the meaning of its oddly specific existence.
Even if that meant leaving potentially thousands
of tortured human explorers eternally lost
in level 18.
The Plush Dino was now embodying the “I
can fix him” mentality to its logical extreme.
After trying several doors throughout Level
21, it was clear that the majority of them
simply led back into other parts of Level
21’s four hallways: much like the doors
in a chase scene from a hanna-barbera cartoon.
Eventually, 682 and his party members stumbled
upon a dimensional tear in the side of one
of the hallways.
This looked enough like the entrance to the
next level, so SCP-682 decided to throw caution
to the wind and step through…
Into Level 22 - The car park, which, unlike
some of the previous levels - was, in fact,
infinite.
For whatever that was worth.
A few damaged 50s-era automobiles occupied
the parking spots, their metal rusted and
torn to shreds.
More curiously, there was what appeared to
be a circus tent wedged between some of the
concrete supports.
There were no entities around in the main
area of Level 21, so SCP-682 entered the tent
- thinking it was perhaps another exit.
For once, it seemed the backrooms weren’t
subverting the reptile’s expectations - as
inside the tent was none other than the inside
of a tent.
Rows of plastic folded chairs sat within,
facing a wooden podium on an elevated stage.
The tent was made to hold many humans, but
strangely there was only one: an old man in
ragged hiking gear stood amidst the chairs,
scribbling notes into a journal of sorts.
He wore an enormous backpack that swelled
with supplies and unusual bottled items.
“So the fallen nation of Emstable lived
inside of tents like this one…”
The old man muttered to himself.
He then looked over his shoulder and noticed
SCP-682 glaring at him.
He closed his journal and stared back with
an inquisitive look on his face.
“Oh!
A new entity!
I don’t get to see that every day!”
The human laughed.
“Though why is it with Entity 7 and Entity
198?”
“If those numbers are so important to you,
mine is 682,” SCP-682 growled.
“Entity 682?” asked the Old Man, scratching
his white beard.
“How have I never heard of you?”
“I’m not an entity.”
682 snapped back.
“I’m an anomaly.”
The Old Man shrugged and said “I fail to
see the distinction.”
That makes two of us, 682 thought.
“Anyway, ‘anomaly’ 682, I’d advise
against attacking me.
I’m rather busy collecting notes for the
Kalag Institute, and I can be a force of nature
when I’m interrupted.
I’ve dealt with bigger and scarier things
than you, so wander off and leave me to my
work.”
The Old Man had far too much confidence for
682’s liking.
Who did this human think he was anyway?
It was not going to be talked down to like
that, especially not by someone from any kind
of “institute.”
It was go-time.
Without another word, the reptile began plowing
through the chairs towards the elderly human
who, in a display of agility unexpected for
someone his age, gracefully hopped across
the chairs to the stage: successfully evading
682’s charge.
“Well, I did warn you.”
The old man reached into his pack and produced
a small, dark object carved of lapis lazuli
stone.
It resembled a scarab - or dung beetle and
there were hieroglyphs across the base of
it.
The old man chanted a prayer to the stone,
invoking the name of the Egyptian god “Khepri”
and causing the scarab’s wings to extend.
A great blue light was emitted from the lapis
stone and a terrible droning buzz hit 682
all at once - stunning it for a moment.
The Old man left the winged beetle hovering
in the air and proceeded to draw two more
unusual objects from his knapsack.
In one hand, he held a bottle of fine red
powder, while the other held a bottle that
appeared to contain electrical energy.
He hurled both at SCP-682, and ducked for
cover behind the stage.
Upon impact, the bottles created a large explosion
of electrical flames which immediately caused
the entire tent to go up.
The Old Man drew a large knife and cut his
way out of the tent, leaving 682 behind to
burn as the structure collapsed.
The human made a break for the nearest concrete
ramp leading down to the lower areas of the
parking garage.
He looked back to see a heavily scorched 682
in hot pursuit, but no signs of Entity 7 Jerry
and Entity 198 the Plush Dino.
The entity, no, the anomaly was more durable
than the old man expected, and far more willing
to endure pain if it meant chasing down prey.
In a desperate bid to keep the monster from
catching him, the old man retrieved a crystal
and metal artifact from his inventory.
It was known as a Pocket and - true to its
name - it contained a pocket-dimension which
could store large objects and release them
at the command of its user.
Earlier in his trip through level 22, the
old man had stored a couple of the damaged
cars in the Pocket in case he needed cover
from an attacking entity.
As 682 gained on him, he summoned the cars
back from the pocket, causing them to land
in the reptile’s path.
While ineffective at stopping the creature,
it gave the old man enough time to take a
sharp turn around a corner and find a hiding
spot among the other tents and broken-down
cars.
The seasoned explorer had one last trick up
his sleeve, and he prayed that it would bring
an end to this terrifying encounter.
As SCP-682 sniffed the air, searching for
him, the Old Man produced another bottle of
unbridled energy - this time derived from
the same kind of dimensional rift found on
Level 21.
He hurled it towards the reptile not a moment
too soon and watched in awe as the bottle
exploded.
The floor and ceiling began to crumble as
arcs of energy surrounded 682.
What is this?
SCP-682 thought, feeling itself being pulled
from this reality and into another.
Seconds later, the reptile was gone in a flash
of energy.
The Old Man wiped his brow in relief.
That was close.
Wherever 682 was after being warped by the
dimensional tear, this particular explorer
had managed to escape its wrath for now.
But would others be so lucky?
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?”
and “SCP-682 Slaughters Through the Backrooms”
for more Backrooms carnage!